Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today
I want to talk about learning
Chinese or Mandarin Chinese
versus, uh, Japanese and Korean.
Remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell to get notifications.
So, uh, I have learned to varying degrees
of fluency, uh, Mandarin Chinese, which
is the first one I learned back in 1968.
Full-time at school, but living in
an environment which was not Mandarin
speaking, in other words, Hong Kong.
Uh, then I learned Japanese basically
on my own, uh, helped by the fact
that I could read Chinese characters.
And of course, living in Japan
for nine years, my Japanese
got progressively better.
And then I said, at some point, I think in
the early eighties, I should learn Korean
because I have invested so much time
into learning, uh, Chinese and Japanese,
but I never had much time for it.
And at different sort of
points I have given it a go.
Three months here, six months there.
And I'm really not very satisfied with
the level that I have achieved in Korean,
but let's compare these three languages.
So they're East Asian languages from a
geographic point of view because these
three countries are located in East Asia.
However, they are not of
the same language family.
Chinese is Sino-Tibetan.
So related to languages in Tibet,
Burma, uh, I don't know all of them.
I'm not a linguist in the sense of being,
you know, someone who studies linguistics.
Of course Japanese, according to some is
related to the sort of, uh,  Ural-Altaic
languages, Korean, Turkish, Mongolian.
There are other people who challenged
that, but it's a completely
different language family, both
of them, Korean and Japanese.
Um, but the underpinning of Japanese and
Chinese in terms of vocabulary is Chinese.
Uh, in the case of Japanese, even their
writing system, their phonetic writing
system derives from Chinese characters.
So China had a major influence on them.
Of course, learning these languages
has become easier than ever.
I learned Chinese and Japanese
at a time when there was no
internet, there were no MP3 files.
There is no way, no online dictionaries.
You certainly couldn't do the things
we do at LingQ, import stuff from
newspapers, from YouTube, from Netflix,
or, um, you know, basically save words
to a database for later review and
all of these things weren't available.
You had a book, you looked things up
in a dictionary, and if you had the
money, you got yourself a teacher.
And if you are lucky enough
to live where the language was
spoken, as I did for Japanese,
then of course you took advantage.
I learn languages because
I'm interested in history.
And so it's important to understand
that what we talk about today as
China, Korea, Japan, and in the case
of China, at one point, whatever,
four or five billion people, uh,
Japan, maybe 125/127 million people.
Uh, Korea would be 50 plus 25, I
don't know the exact number for
North Korea, 75 million people.
Those are large language groups.
And as I said, Chinese, insofar as
vocabulary is concerned, is the base.
More than half of all of the words
used in Chinese and Japanese,
especially in more serious content,
much as is the case in English where
much of our more sort of serious...
okay, academic vocabulary comes
from French in the case of Japanese
and Korean comes from Chinese.
So geographically, we consider East
Asia as an area where you look at
China, but it's important to remember
that, you know, homosapians came out
of Africa, spread all over the world,
moved eastward towards, uh, Asia.
Maybe to some extent and increasingly
people feel there were some, you
know, intermingling with, uh,
previous, um, call it homosapiens.
Like we are homosapien sapiens.
So, you know, Neanderthal or
the equivalent in Asia might
have had its contribution.
I just don't know, but it's possible.
Because things they said were not the case
before it turns out they do more research
and they discover for example, that, uh,
many human or homosapian sapians did mix
with Neanderthals, um, at any rate...
so if you look at a map of, of human
movements 50,000 years ago, you see
people moving through China, moving
from the North, down to the South.
Uh, even the Ainu supposedly, sort
of indigenous to the, to Japan.
They came over from the mainland.
Uh, there's no one indigenous to Japan.
They didn't spring out of
the ground like mushrooms.
They came from somewhere.
They might've come via a sea route.
And there are theories that people went
to Japan via Shanghai and originated
in Southern China, or that they
came across their Korean peninsula.
This is 2000 odd years ago.
So at some point things
sort of solidified.
And there is the sense that at least in
terms of, uh, you know, genetics, not
that that matters, but, uh, Japanese
with their, Ainu sort of mixture
and the Koreans and the Mongolians
and the Manchurians, uh, there...
and the Northern Chinese there
sort of one group, Tibetans,
even though the Chinese and the
buttons are closer, linguistically.
And then the Southern Chinese,
Southeast Asians, that's sort of
like somewhat different groups
with a lot of scrambling going on.
And of course, historically a lot
of those peoples in central or in,
in inner Asia call it, Mongolians
and the Khitans and the Tanguts and
the Manchus and the Jurchens , they
were quite powerful in their own
right.
And at various times
conquered they're neighbors.
And so lots went on before we
ended up with what we got today.
So that's just a little,
I like that kind of stuff.
And so then of course, uh, over
the last few thousand years, these
countries have developed distinctive,
you know, histories of their own.
And they developed a language of
their own each one of them and
a writing system of their own.
And in the case of Chinese, the writing
system is exclusively pictograms,
each character represents meaning.
Not always identifiable in terms of
sort of pictoral or image wise, although
you can with explanations, see how it's
derived from something that we could
visualize, but mostly it's, it's an idea.
So it's an ideogram.
Yeah, I guess that's
the way to describe it.
And most of those ideograms have a
phonetic component, uh, and that's
where the kanna that's used Japanese...
in japanese they have these ideograms,
but they also have two parallel phonetic
scripts, which derive from certain
Chinese characters, which were used
to represent sounds in Japanese and
then eventually evolved into kanna.
And this happened about, you
know, 980 or so, uh, part of that
whole range of influence that came
over from China, uh, artistic,
religious, literary, and so forth.
Uh, in the case of Korea, somewhere
around the 15th century, supposedly
their King created Hangul,
which is, um, a phonetic writing system
that started from scratch and has no
influence from Chinese characters.
So that's in so far as the
writing system is concerned.
Um, as far as, you know, the, the,
uh, Romanization or the phonetic
writing system that we can use to
get a sense of how these words are
pronounced when we don't yet know
Hangul or we don't yet know Hiragana,
uh, the Chinese use Pinyin, which was
developed, uh, you know, after 1949
and replaced previous systems that
had been created by, by foreigners.
Uh, personally I thought that Yale
Romanization system was better because
in Pinyin they use letters like Q
and X in ways that we are used to.
So Q has a "ch" sound.
Because theoretically, the "ch" in
Chinese is a little different from "ch".
So they've got a different symbol.
The similarly, the X is a "shi" Xi,
which is different from S kind of
between "Sh" and S, so use an X.
So if you get a name card from a
Chinese person and they've got Qs
and Xs in there, you'll be quite
confused until you get used to it.
But once you get used to it, it's
actually quite a practical system.
The Japanese use a Romanization system.
There's two, there's the one that is
the most helpful is one where, you know,
if you have a word like hatchimitsu,
which is, um, honey, uh, then the hatchi
, chi is CH, and Mitsu "tsu" is TSU.
However, in the Japanese writing
system, in Hiragana or Katakana,
uh, because you have sort of.
Sets of these...these are syllables.
So you have sets of ka, ki, ku, ke, ko.
Ha, hi, hu, he, ho.
And then it goes, uh, Ta that uses
the T sound TA, ta, chi, tsu, te, to.
So in the Japanese system, the
T becomes a "chi" and a "tsu".
So they, they decide that therefore
for the poor foreigner, trying
to pronounce the word hatchimitsu
we should write it to be pure H A
T I M I T U, Hatimitu, which might
be, you know, close to the Japanese
system but it's useless for a
non-Japanese speaker trying to figure
out how to pronounce a Japanese word.
Fortunately, that's not used
too much except by the purists.
Now in Korean, they have a Romanization
system, which I find the least useful
because it uses the letter E
in all kinds of different ways.
And I'm never clear whether this is a,
some kind of a dipthong or an attempt
to, to, uh, represent, you know,
uh, this, "uh", sound, eh, I never
know quite what it's trying to do.
And sometimes it seems to have a Y, uh,
role whenever I see the, the, uh, Korean,
uh, Romanization, I'd just ignore it.
I, if I'm reading on the
internet, I'll use text to speech,
uh, or I'll use the Hangul.
So it's really not very helpful,
but again, developed by, you
know, the ministry of education.
So a whole bunch of very serious people
came up with this thing as somehow being,
uh, I dunno, close to the original Korean.
So that's so far as the writing system
and the, uh, call it transliteration
or Romanization systems used.
In any case, I think you have to listen,
you can't rely on the, uh, Romanization.
You have to get yourself used to
seeing something written with their
phonetic script, which doesn't exist in
Chinese and then how it's pronounced.
And if you do enough listening,
you gradually get used to
it in the case of all three.
So that's...
we've covered the writing systems,
the differences, the romanticization
differences, um, Pronunciation.
Obviously the biggest problem
in Chinese is the tones.
And there are no tones in Japanese
or Korean because remember
Japanese and Korean belong to
a different language family.
So tonal language is Thai,
you know, Vietnamese,
Tibetan, I guess I'm assuming.
Cause Sino-Tibetan, whatever.
But Japanese and Korean are not tonal.
So to get the tones, I found it very
difficult to try to remember the
individual tones, um, with your reading.
If you're reading on LingQ, the
tones are marked, a lot of places
they will give you marks, you know.
So they'll show you what tone it is.
And by the end of reading a lot,
in Pinyin, with the tone marks, you
gradually start to get used to it.
But the bigger thing is
do a lot of listening.
Focus on phrases so that these
natural phrases come out with the
natural tones and, and recognize
that you're going to start out at
30% accuracy moved to 40, 50, 60, 70.
You'll never be a hundred, but
you'll get closer and closer.
Uh, so tone is not a problem in Japanese.
However, there are people who
claim that there is this, uh,
pitch tone issue in Japanese.
I have, I wasn't even aware
of it when I lived in Japan.
Nobody has trouble understanding me.
I don't think it's an important issue
unless you are some kind of a purist
that you want to, you know, be a
hundred percent like a native, but
then, then the issue becomes which
pitch tone are you going to copy?
Because the pitch seems to me
quite different in Osaka than
it is in Sendai or in Tokyo.
So I think it's more important to pick up
on, and this is true for all languages,
pick up on the natural intonation, the
natural rhythm, uh, of the language.
Try not to introduce, for
example, English intonation into
Japanese or Korean: "watashi wa".
They don't say that.
It's a little more monotonous, more like
French, and you have to catch, you know,
you get ahold of that intonation by, by
dint of doing a lot of listening without
trying to worry about is this sound,
which pitch and stuff, at least for
me, not something I spend any time on.
I would far rather increase my
vocabulary, increase my comprehension.
And in doing so I will increase my
ability to communicate effectively.
Uh, Korean I found that the
pronunciation actually is quite
similar to, uh, to Japanese.
Of course, the words are different.
In fact, some words sound the same
and are completely different from
Japanese, but I find this, the
pronunciation is if you can pronounce
the one, you can pronounce the other.
And in terms of European languages,
You know, Greek, Spanish, any of these
languages where you have few diphthongs,
basically pure vowels, it's going to
be similar to those two languages.
Okay.
Grammar, generally speaking,
having studied Slavic languages,
Romance languages, German.
Um, I find the Asian language is more
forgiving when it comes to grammar.
Uh, it's harder to make a mistake.
They're more flexible.
I go today.
I go tomorrow.
I go yesterday.
Um, not quite, but almost.
In Japanese, there is a clearer
sort of indication and in Korean,
uh, of tense, not so much in
Chinese, uh, no gender, no number.
Um, yeah, it's, it's, it's easier.
Uh, this is somewhat compensated or at
least the, the, the counterpart to that is
the different levels of politeness.
Uh, what the linguistic students call
register, you know, it's, it's quite
a bit more differentiated than say
in English or in European languages.
So you have to be a little careful.
Uh, I therefore try to keep it
neutral in Japanese and Korean.
Don't wander too far down the
sort of casual side of things.
And I don't go too far into the
very formal, polite kind of thing.
Stay neutral until you
get very good at it.
And then you'll have a sense
of, of what, what form of a word
verb or whatever is appropriate.
Less of a problem in Chinese.
Normally they're not as
polite or as formalized as the
Japanese and the, uh, Koreans.
Um, now another issue when learning a
language is the availability of content.
And, uh, to that extent, I was very
lucky when I studied Mandarin Chinese
because the Yale in China series had
had such a broad range of material:
beginner material, um, you know,
books on geography, history with
500 characters, 1000 characters.
A range of, of, uh, reading
material with glossaries behind
every chapter or every page, uh,
on literature history, you name it.
Uh, communist propaganda,
whatever it might be.
It, it was complete.
I did not find that to be
the case with Japanese.
I had to regularly scour the
bookstores to find any kind of reading
material with, with the glossary.
Uh, of course easier today because you
can, you can find content, uh, Uh, you
can go to these automatic transcription
sites, get it transcribed, bring it
into LingQ, for example, study it.
So it has become a lot
easier in that regard.
The same is...
even worse with Korean.
One of the reasons why I would sort of
go out Korean for a while and then stop,
is that there, there is an abundance
of beginner to intermediate material
in Korean: uninteresting, uninspired
narrators, very difficult to listen to.
Uh, a lot of emphasis on, you know, older
sister, younger sister, second cousin,
uncle, third aunt, all the sort of details
of, of different words used for relatives.
I don't have any Korean relatives.
To me, that's just...
and it's part of this general
trend in all three languages,
those people who create texts, the
native speakers of those languages,
put a lot of effort into, you know,
festivals and traditional foods and
things of that nature, which are
therefore less familiar to us and less
difficult, less, more difficult to get
into, at least as far as I'm concerned.
I like to hear about how people
lead their everyday lives.
And of course the, the voice is important.
It has to have resonance.
You have to connect with that voice.
People, natural conversations, uh,
about things in our daily lives
often, you know, natural conversations
subsequently transcribed, this kind
of thing is, is, is much better.
But so in so far as the accessibility
and availability of, of learning
material, uh, better now than before,
because of our ability to connect to
netflix and YouTube, people who like
Korean drama or Japanese or Chinese drama
can find those things to learn from.
So just trying to touch on some of the
main areas, uh, that influence people
who are studying these three languages.
They are all worth it.
Those are important centers of
a history, of culture, of people
that we want to get to know.
They're all a little different.
They're all well worth
learning for their own reasons.
Okay.
There you have it.
And I'm going to leave a couple of
suggested videos, one in Japanese,
one in Korean that are these one
in Chinese and one, and, uh, in, in
Japanese that might want to listen to,
to get a sense, uh, of those languages.
Okay.
Bye.
For now.